why do people fail in Hollywood I
actually think more people failed in
Hollywood and then succeed because it's
it's a game and what people don't
understand is the game changes
everything you have to know how the
machine works and if you don't know how
the machine works you're not going to
get your work out there and you will not
have doors opening for your success and
I think also some people stumble and
fail because they haven't taken the time
to develop their craft to storytellers
and filmmakers you really have to have
it down you really have to know craft
you've got to know ready to put the
camera
bloodlines to use what is the lighting
what is the rhythm tempo and pacing what
is being revealed on the scene where is
the climax where is the point of
ignition where is the aftermath where
does it pick up again where does it end
you have to know these things otherwise
you're going to have a really hard time
making a successful film it's craft
craft craft craft craft and the best way
to learn filmmaking is go out and make
films every time you make a film you
learn I'm still learning I feel like I
just scratched the surface in terms of
what it what is it to make a good film I
like what you say about the rules change
hadn't really thought of that that's
really interesting so how does somebody
then start to know what the rules are if
no one's telling you but they're
changing you have to circulate and you
have to read the trades you have to be
informed you have to gather intelligence
I'm not gonna mention names but there's
an actor who recently fell from grace
and he was at a store project of mine
that project is now gone because his
fall was so dark and tragic and severe
and toxic that so the game changed from
my relationship with his actor because
of what happened that things are
changing you know every day I pitched a
series to a network that was red
to be greenlit and the day we were
supposed to sign the papers the channel
hired a new person to take over and just
a new person said I'm not green lighting
any project that my predecessor greenlit
so I'm sorry you can have to piss this
someone else changes had another TV show
where I had two very famous shell
writers a week before we were supposed
to go sign the deal one of them got
named to run a network but you don't cry
in in weep about these things go okay
this wasn't meant to be let's keep going
keep going it changes every day it
changes and you have to be informed you
have to gather intelligence and talk to
people in the industry and read the
trades
you